hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter 17 of thomas hobbes leviathan
begins part two of the work and it's
titled of the causes generation and
definition
of a commonwealth so all the things that
he's been discussing
up to that point in setting out the
human condition
and thinking about you know how we can
get ourselves
out of a state that we don't want to be
in into a state that we do want to be in
is is being brought to a crux
here and the answer to the problems
is going to be what he will call the
sovereign by the end
of the chapter and so there's a bit of
you could say review sort of you know
rehearsing the
the basic argument that's being done
early on in the chapter about the human
condition and this is going to lead
through to
having this this sort of
answer to the fundamental question
so he tells us that human beings
naturally love liberty
and dominion over others and that's
already a bit problematic right
we all want to have our own freedom we
want to enjoy the rights that we have in
a state of nature where we get to do
anything that
our own desires reversions lead us to
and yet some of those would conflict
with those of
others not only do we have the issue of
competition
where we both want the same thing but i
might interfere with
somebody else as well in other ways
and you know i have to anticipate their
reactions they're anticipating
my reactions but we also like to
dominate each other we like to
be higher up than others and so
it's not simply a matter of you know
economic competition or something like
that
there is a psychological dynamic that
makes things particularly
conflict prone so he begins by saying
the final cause
and or design of men who naturally love
liberty
and dominion over others in the
introduction of that restraint
upon themselves in which we see them
live in commonwealths
so we've already got two things there
what is that restraint well the
recognition of the laws of nature
that he sketched out into previous
chapters those
articulate what the restraint
would look like and he goes on and then
says
is the foresight of their own
preservation
and of a more contented life thereby
that is to say of getting themselves out
from that miserable condition of war
which is necessarily consequent
to the natural passions of men when
there is
no visible power to keep them in on so
in that very first
paragraph we've got so much being
referred to so much going on without
some visible or as he said in earlier
chapters
common power to enforce the rules to
enforce the laws of nature
and to keep people from following their
passions
and also he says to tie them by fear of
punishment to the performance of their
covenants
and observation of those laws of nature
we're not going to have what it is that
we want
self-preservation and an enjoyable
life in which we can count on keeping
our property or
if we spend the time to you know learn
things we can actually apply them so
this is the human condition
and how do we get out of it well
you know there's there's a possibility
that maybe we could just sort of
associate with each other we'll talk
about that in a moment let's go on and
talk about the laws of nature part he
says
the laws of nature of themselves without
the terror
of some power to cause them to be
observed are contrary to our natural
passions
that carry us to partiality pride
revenge and the like so that's a problem
right
laws of nature we can recognize them by
reason
we can say they bind as hobbs has told
us
inforo internal inside of ourselves
but to get people to follow them when
they go against our natural passions
we need some sort of enforcement
mechanism
he also tells us that covenants without
the sword
are but words and have no strength to
secure a man
at all so that's a problem too i make
agreements with you that
you know go beyond the laws of nature
although there is that law of nature
uh the third one that if we make
covenants we observe them we we keep
them with other people
without some sort of authority figure
uh some sort of executive uh function
some sort of what is he's going to call
it later on magistrate who can
exert force and punish people are not
going to
keep their agreements even if they enter
into them
intending to because their reasonings
and their passions are going to lead
them to do
other things they're going to cut
corners they're going to make exceptions
for themselves
they'll make excuses oh it's only this
one time
and if we do that if we allow that to
happen
things are going to break down so how do
we how do we
move past this this is really the
central question and he tells us that
there's one other little note that i
want to bring in here
he mentions that there are places where
people have lived by small
families and you know they
are following laws of honor but but not
the
actual laws of not the natural laws they
followed what he calls the law of nature
which is just to
if you know if you think about the the
first one if you don't have some sort of
authority figure if you don't have some
sort of decider
well then look out for yourselves and
maybe look out for your family so this
is another depiction of the
state of nature we could have a
multitude
as he says and he uses that term
deliberately a multitude is a bunch of
people gathered together
couldn't we have some sort of order
spontaneously
arise maybe through customs
and institutions that allows them to
function
as a society without any political
authority
he says it it is not the joining
together of a small number of
people that gives security in small
numbers small addition on the one side
of the greater
make the advantage of strength so great
as is sufficient to carry the victory
what if we have a bigger
multitude to protect us from outside
sources
right that might try to take our stuff
the multitude sufficient to confide in
our security is not determined by any
certain number
but by comparison with the enemy we fear
and is then sufficient when the odds of
the enemy are not so
of so visible and conspicuous moment to
determine the event of war
but he says even if there was a massive
multitude
if their actions be directed according
to their particular
judgments if each person is deciding for
themselves
in particular appetites they can expect
thereby no defense nor protection
against a common enemy so people might
come in from the
outside people who are not in your
whatever tribe
group you know and they'll try to take
your stuff
because you know this is the human
condition
even if you can organize the defense
against them
you still have another problem as hobbes
goes on
he says that this multitude not only
can't protect you against a common enemy
nor against the injuries of one another
being distracted in opinions concerning
the best use and application of their
strength they don't help but hinder each
other
and reduce their strength by mutual
opposition to nothing
when there is no common enemy they make
war upon each other and so this is a a
big problem
isn't it he also goes on and he says
listen if you could just have a whole
bunch of people get together
and produce a a functioning
society without any political authority
over them
we'd already see that that would be
happening that would take place
and this is kind of an interesting
argument that that he's making
right so agreement and performance and
peace isn't something that will just
occur happen on its own and then he's
got this interesting comparison
between us and bees now he says
aristotle
called bees and ants they they're
political creatures because they live
sociably
with one another and you know they're
basically like us they're meat machines
they
they have passions and appetites they
can work well together
why can't we and he says we're different
than those
first we're in competition for honor and
dignity ants and bees don't care about
that sort of thing
second among these creatures the common
good doesn't differ from the private
another big
difference with us but here's a really
important one the third
these creatures having not as man the
use of reason
do not think do not see or think they
see any fault in the administration of
their common
business whereas human beings this is
one of the things that rationality
does in fact make possible for us and it
doesn't have to be in terms of like the
political organization
think about any enterprise that human
beings
do there's always somebody who's like i
think you could have done that better
i should be in charge you know or you
should take advice from me
i mean i can't think of how many
comments i have
on videos of people who've never done a
thing like that in their life
who know all about how i should be doing
videos right
and they come in with is steady stream
enough that i actually
created a response video for people who
are giving unwanted advice
this is a dynamic of human nature
according to hobbes right
he also says these creatures though they
have some use of voice
they want that art of words by which
some men can represent to others that
which is good in the likeness of evil
and evil in the likeness of good
and so you know we can use language to
conceal to to lie to manipulate and and
they don't do that
with with each other he says also
um irrational creatures can't
distinguish between
injury and damage and so they're not
that offended
with with other uh members of their own
species
and lastly says the agreement to these
creatures is natural
that of men is by covenant only which is
artificial we're going to come back to
that
in in a moment so
what are our prospects then hobbs says
well you know
we could um
erect a sovereign and this is different
than having a multitude he says the only
way to erect such a common power
that we you know we can get what we want
uh is to confer
all their power and strength upon one
man
or upon one assembly of men that may
reduce
all their wills by plurality of voices
into
one will which is as much to say
to appoint one man or assembly of men to
bear their person
and everyone to own and acknowledge
himself to be the author
of whatsoever he that so beareth their
person shall act or cause to be acted
in those things which concern the common
peace and safety
here's another key thing therein to
submit their wills everyone to his will
and their judgments to his judgment so
we we establish an authority who is
above us
and they although they were from us one
among us they're in a privileged
position
we take what they say as being
you know the final uh determination
we allow their will to become
our will and if our wills conflict with
them then we have to
knuckle under and find some way to to
agree with us
we reduce all this multitude of jarring
wills
into one capital w will you might say
and hobbes thinks that this is rather
distinctive
what this does is has each of us here's
where we get the social
contract theory we all covenant with
each other
he says this is more than consent or
concord
it is a real unity of them all in one
and the same person
made by covenant of every man with every
man in such manner
as if every man should say to every man
now notice
as if they should say i authorize and
give up my right of governing myself to
this man or to this assembly on this
condition
that you give up your right to him and
authorize all his actions in like manner
this is the social contract we all agree
with each other
that we're going to give up certain of
our rights and which include the right
to make judgments about some things and
to engage in opposition
to the authority figure the sovereign
and i do it because
you're going to do it too so i you know
think about monopoly of force we give
the sovereign a monopoly on deadly force
and we say we're not going to
impose deadly force upon each other
except
perhaps in very extreme circumstances
like a home invasion
and i do it because you're going to do
it i'm i'm
only doing it because you're going to do
it that's that's how it works with this
agreement and as as hob says this
generates
uh he calls this is the generation of
that great leviathan
or rather to speak more reverently of
that mortal god
to which we owe under the immortal god
our peace
and defense so
it could be a single person it could be
a power structure as we say it could be
an assembly
but there's going to be some sort of
person or persons in charge
and that's what we call the sovereign
the last thing that we have to talk
about
is and this goes back to the issue of
nature
hobbes then says well there's there's
actually two different ways in which
this can happen
which is good for him in part because an
immediate objection
to uh his doctrine in most places would
be
man we never made any sort of agreement
like this what are you talking about
how are you saying that the king or the
president or the
premier or whoever the mayor why are
they in charge i didn't vote for them
i they just happened to be there and so
hobbs says
there's two ways of attaining to this
sovereign power one is by what he calls
natural force this is different than the
nature that he was talking about with
bees and ants where it's just their
instincts
or their programming or whatever we're
going to say natural force is when
somebody imposes force
on somebody else and one prime example
of this is he says
if a person buy war subdues their
enemies to his will giving them their
lives on that condition so you
take over somebody's territory and you
say listen i'll let you live
but you're going to do things my way i'm
the sovereign
and you're kind of stuck with my will
it's in according to hobbs their
interest
to go along with that the other example
of that that he uses that some of you
may
say well that's that's kind of strange
sounding he says
when a man maketh his children to submit
themselves
and their children to his government as
being able to destroy
them if they refuse now that's some
pretty interesting child rearing there
um so you know make of that what you
will but the idea is that within the
family
the the patriarch or it could be a
matriarch whoever it's going to be
has power over the the children and then
their children and
it goes on from from there the other way
is in the manner that he's just talked
about right
he talks about men agreeing amongst
themselves to submit
to some man or assembly of man
voluntarily
on confidence to be produced by him
against all others
this can be called a political
commonwealth or commonwealth by
institution and that's what what hobbs
is primarily
going to be focused on uh in this
although he does you know
leave a lot of scope for commonwealth by
acquisition
as he says and we we should come back to
this thing as well
was there ever at any time for most
people
a social contract you know like those of
us who are born into societies
that have been around for a long time
did we actually
engage in this sort of thing saying i
authorize and give up my right of
government no no
but he says it's um as if
every person should say so this is set
in a kind of
hypothetical or you could say it's an
implicit agreement
hobbs thinks of authority within
functioning civil societies
as working more or less this way that we
in order to get the things that we want
we have to
recognize the authority of
the sovereign
you